müssen wir die erde verlassen die
ressourcen werden knapper der
klimawandel setzt der erde zur
überbevölkerung umweltverschmutzung
stephen hawking sagt ja wir müssen weg
aber wohin wunschthema bei whatsapp
terraforming wie können fremde planeten
für uns menschen bewohner gemacht werden
der mars beispielsweise als eine zweite
erde und das innerhalb weniger
jahrhunderte wie das gehen soll und wie
realistisch das wirklich ist jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
der mars ist tatsächlich ein planet auf
dem leben zumindest theoretisch
vorstellbar ist und das aus
verschiedenen gründen beispielsweise hat
er zumindest eine dünne atmosphäre die
vor kosmischer strahlung schützt zum
anderen sind dort die temperaturen
hinnehmbar und es gibt genug sonnenlicht
das man nutzen könnte zudem ist der tag
nacht rhythmus auf dem mars dem der erde
sehr ähnlich ein tag auf diesem planeten
dauert 24 stunden 39 minuten und 35
sekunden
natürlich können menschen nicht einfach
so ohne technische hilfsmittel jahren
umziehen aber im vergleich zur venus ist
der mars ein paradies das sagen
zumindest die verantwortlichen des
projektes mars rang die schon in naher
zukunft menschen für immer auf dem mars
siedeln lassen wollen wir hatten ja
darüber berichtet doch fest steht auch
ohne technische hilfsmittel ist sein
leben auf dem mars unvorstellbar das
stichwort der science-fiction-literatur
terraforming um den böden trocknen maß
quasi in eine zweite erde zu verwandeln
es gab zeiten in denen der mars wohl
warm war
und tatsächlich auch flüssiges wasser
auf seiner oberfläche hat doch seine
atmosphäre und das wasser sind vor etwa
3,8 bis 3,5 milliarden jahren
verschwundene zum einen liegt das an
seiner geringen masse zum anderen fehlen
ihm ein heißer kern und ein magnetfeld
das ihn schützen könnte und so ist der
mars ausgekühlt denn der sonnenwind
konnte ihn ungehindert angreifen und ihm
seine atmosphäre nehmen das wasser
verdunstet zum teil der andere teil
versickerte wurde in tiefere schichten
und um den mars wieder lebens
freundlicher zu machen bräuchte er eine
dichtere atmosphäre die sich atmen lässt
die temperatur auf seiner oberfläche
würde sich dann erhöhen und wasser
könnte in flüssiger form existieren
unabdingbar für leben auf dem mars zudem
würde der angesammelte wasser dampf in
der atmosphäre für einen treibhauseffekt
sorgen so dass sich die temperatur
weiter erhöht klingt alles ziemlich easy
ist es aber in der realität dann doch
nicht oder etwa wohl
es gibt verschiedene ideen
mikroorganismen könnten mit ihrem
stoffwechsel die atmosphäre des mars für
uns optimieren
man könnte das eis durch gezielte
asteroiden bombardements schmelzen
lassen
oder aber mit spiegeln in seiner
umlaufbahn seine oberfläche aufheizen
aber es gibt nicht nur kurios klingen
die vision sondern tatsächlich auch
wissenschaftliche studien dazu
der fachbegriff 4eco jesus der
knackpunkt ist wohl tatsächlich in
erster linie die erwärmung des planeten
1984 schlug der physiker james lovelock
treibhausgase in die atmosphäre zu
bringen vor so genannte perfluorcarbon
pfc hunderte produktionsanlagen so große
autos ließen dann die mars
oberflächentemperatur innerhalb von 100
jahren um 20 grad steigen
love rocks berechnungen von minus 60
grad auf minus 40 grad celsius das co2
aus den polen würde in die atmosphäre
über gilt als treibhausgas würde es für
eine weitere temperatursteigerung song
auf etwa plus 20 grad celsius innerhalb
von 600 jahren ja schnell geht das
wirklich nicht das wassereis würde sich
verflüssigen was die bildung von
mehreren und seen zur folge hätte durch
einen hohen atmosphärendruck würde die
verdunstung verhindert werden innerhalb
einiger jahrhunderte während der mars
also warm und feucht relativ perfekte
lebensbedingungen nötig wäre dann noch
für uns menschen ein sauerstoff atmen
system etwa sowie taucher sie nutzen
doch paszek da wäre es natürlich wenn
sich das co2 in der atmosphäre sogar in
sauerstoff umwandeln ließ die idee algen
die viel co2 aushalten
dadurch könnten dann auch pflanzen auf
dem mars gedeihen doch leider ist die
photosynthese der pflanzen zu diesem
zwecke nicht wirklich effektiv
schätzungen zufolge würde es eine
million jahre in anspruch nehmen das co2
das maß in so viel sauerstoff zu
verwandeln dass wir dort atmen können
würmer und insekten könnten schon
deutlich früher auf dem mars leben als
wir
doch das große aber würde die so
entstandene mars atmosphäre überhaupt
bestehen bleiben würde nicht wieder eine
erosion durch den sonnen mit stattfinden
diese ganzen prozesse sind noch lange
nicht ganz verstanden doch vermutlich
würde die atmosphäre erstmal für eine
zeit bestehenbleiben eine dauerhafte
lösung allerdings wäre dieses
terraforming des mars nicht das ganze
zeigt uns einmal mehr dass wir bislang
nicht wirklich eine alte
diese zu unserer erde als lebensraum
haben wieder ein grund mehr etwas besser
auf sie aufzupassen um unseren planeten
und somit auch uns noch lange zu
erhalten wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema mars besiedelung da ist ja einiges
im gange und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollten dann endet meine
telefonnummer hier bei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr als erstes von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
und zu brüsten habe ich noch ein kleines
goodie für euch einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
1000 raketen zum masters in der die
pläne von allen masc ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran